NATASHA:
I used to have nothing.
And then I got this job…
This family…
But nothing lasts forever.
THADDEUS:
I heard you had to leave in a hurry.
NATASHA:
It’s never easy these days.
♪♪
THADDEUS:
So what are you going to do?
NATASHA:
I’ve lived a lot of lives...
But I’m done running from my past.
YELENA:
I know you're out there.
NATASHA:
I know you know I'm out here.
So are we going to talk like grownups?
YELENA:
Is that what we are?
NATASHA:
It's good to see you too-
Sis.
YELENA:
What brings you home?
♪♪
NATASHA:
We have unfinished business.
We have to go back to where it all started.
YELENA:
Lucky us.
NATASHA:
One thing's for sure…
It's gonna be a hell of a reunion.
ALEXEI:
Still fits.
Family…
Back together again.
MELINA:
You got fat.
♪♪